so let's get to Jeff buguese who is also
in Atlanta and you mentioned the
District Attorney there mark Jeff you
spoke to that District Attorney of the
Fulton County District Attorney he's
going to make the decision as to whether
to charge one or both of those officers
so good morning to you and what did he
tell you good morning Tony he says that
he is still reviewing the evidence
thoroughly that's what he told us and
he's trying to determine and this is the
heart of the issue whether the officer
felt his life was in danger before he
fired those fatal shots I think that we
have to make a change in this country
Fulton County District Attorney Paul
Howard knows that he is under a
microscope and that charging an officer
with murder is extremely rare how hard
is it to bring charges in cases like
these for you who has stolen a
day-to-day basis work with law
enforcement we as prosecutors have got
to quit offering that excuse one of the
most important things that a prosecutor
can do is to charge a policeman
investigators are examining body cam and
surveillance footage and howard revealed
for the first time that he is looking
into whether officers may have picked up
shell casings at the scene after the
shooting so you could be considering
tampering with evidence among other
charges that's correct
based on what you see in that tape was
use of force necessary was it necessary
probably not necessary Jason Johnson was
in charge of training when he served as
deputy police commissioner in Baltimore
he says not all use of force cases are
cut and dry even with video you have an
actively resistant person whose were
removed to taser from a police officer
fled turn around
apparently deployed the Taser there's
always the potential he could
incapacitate the officer the recent
death is a black man in police custody
and the protests they have led to are
impacting policing across the country
Nashville in Seattle became the latest
cities to ban chokeholds yesterday a
policy shift becoming more common since
Minneapolis paying them after George
Floyd's death
and in New York City Police Commissioner
Dermot Shay announced that he was
disbanding the department's anti-crime
unit 600 plain clothes officers will be
reassigned to other duties to help build
trust with the communities they serve
make no mistake this is a seismic shift
in the culture of how the NYPD police is
this great city and still across the
country the protests continue with
demonstrators demanding more we have
heard them say that they want officers
held accountable if they commit crimes
we'll see what happens here tomorrow in
Atlanta
Kayle well that's a big part of the
frustration Jeff people don't feel that
offers have officers have been held
accountable
I'm curious it's still hard when you see
that he was running away he was shot in
the back police knew he did not have a
gun and they say that a Taser is not a
lethal weapon so you can't have it both
ways and say now that the officer was in
fear of his life what are you hearing on
the ground about that it's just hard to
look at that video knowing he was
running around running away and they
knew he didn't have a gun and they knew
who he was
it's very very difficult and it's tough
to watch that video and we've heard from
police union officials that believe you
know just-just they're asking that the
public withhold judgment at this time
let the investigation play out but as
you know to Gail it is tough video to
watch and at the heart of this is
whether the officer felt threatened and
the DA was pretty vocal about the fact
that he is looking into it and he will
if he believes a crime has been
committed he will bring charges and the
other disturbing thing it happened while
the world is watching a lot of a lot of
questions here Jeff thank you very much